les petites questions pour commencer
jean michel maire c'est pour vous un
abcès des sas parce que cette saison
jean michel legros lourd s'est
transformé en grand séducteur
jean mich est un petit cul sexy sa cible
numéro 1 géraldine
d'autres des chiens
pour eux absents aujourd'hui le tombeur
de ces dames mais surtout le sniper
officiers et oui cette année jean millet
devenu l'homme qu'yvan plus vite que son
ombre avec toi je ne sais pas comment il
faut aborder ne pas aborder du tout
derrière vous venus en masse à moussa
sow
moi je travaille ici j'avoue y aurait
beaucoup ça se verra quand jean-michel
c'est aussi des interventions très
pertinentes sur les médias et ça marche
que là ce qui m'a tant que ça n'étonne
plus personne que les gens sont bien
mais son télé crochet enfin quand on
compense qui dit la copa kids et misery
la mécano à ce film si les patients la
thaïlande est une réplique devenue culte
a cherché à cacher la chasse
achille chroniqueur historique de
l'émission jean-mi nous a encore régalé
cette saison et ça ça mérite des
félicitations
vim matthieu delormeau
ça commence par mois au lit je vous
appeler ben oui bon foot franchement
aussi loin que je me souvienne je ne
t'ai pas vu faire une mauvaise émission
alors c'est vrai qu'on est amis le soir
à tous les jours mais ici on est très
honnête tu es le meilleur aujourd'hui en
deux jeux mais très franchement je me
demande tu es le meilleur aujourd'hui
après tu es un génie
tut tut tut bafouillé tu remplis et
celle de théâtre t'as pas regardé une
émission de plus grand bleu de patrick
sébastien qui te donne à chaque fois
perd la vie le grand bleu c'est un film
le grand battu de ma vie caniveau
culture donne un avis hyper éclaire été
intelligent tu es beau gosse tu es
séduisant franchement tu aurais le
charisme en plus que j'ai tutoyé la
perfection
bref je te le dis tu es mon ami tu es
vraiment devenu un ennemi aujourd'hui
grâce à cette émission j'ai rencontré un
homme et un ami donc grâce à cette bonne
nouvelle rencontre pendant tes yeux je
te mets la dot de 11 et 11 mai sa guise
tout cas c'est ce que je me suis mon
émission ce la fin d'un but
alors je mets 10 dallaire descendre mais
ouais tu sais quoi melon toi à t'emmerde
à nous
oui mais voilà quatre mois mais il faut
qu'ils sortent ya sanction la daïra ya 5
6 ans et les massacres le syndic thomas
s'accrocher on dirait que tu pourras pas
compétitif à la violence mais j'aime les
bonnes c'est parti vite quand j'ai pas
retenu alors qu'est ce qui permettra
juste que je vais prier ou je te
frapperaient jamais si tu prends
l'antenne your antennes
je me suis je t'aime quand armand ok
alors si c'est passé bain et cie s'est
passé pas c'est pas une traque
ouais c'est la fin d'année page c'est la
fin
[Applaudissements]
on veut des gitans mois les rouges sont
des bijoux n'emmerde dont merde
[Applaudissements]
enfin mon pool tu réalises n'entend pas
l'émission va terminer je vous massacrer
il est où il était venu en poules
ceausescu
[Rires]
déjà je vous le dis ce soir jean-luc pas
payer de leur ropa sur ça c'est sûr et
sa version on peut passer alors quoi
même si on sait ce que c'est alors il
faut s'excuser mais bien alors on met on
s'excuse on est payés oui
non mais tu es à chappaqua pas de bien
m'excuser je pourrais je bien m'excuser
je veux te payer donc c'est bon vous
excuser oui bien sûr c'est trop facile
ce qui la font à l'aller moi je parle
des chiens mais vous savez qu'il va
avoir des sanctions
paris souhaite évidemment vous deviez
faire le 18 heures c'est comme ça ouais
vous la jouer comme ça oui oui mais je
trouve ça minable mais bon c'est bien
pour que belinda ce que je peux à mon
prochain
moi qui le fais le fasse bah oui un
câlin ouais bah moi je suis content pour
la mairie et vous donner sinon c'était
pas pour elle c'est sérieux ben ouais
ouais bon sondage suis contre et 2 face
à tous les papas de fierté
je m'excuse pour tout à leur merci
vraiment dépassé ma pensée est venu
d'ailleurs vous sortez mélanie je ne
sors pas souvent vers douala sans rossi
allez allez
elle vit
[Applaudissements]
tu sors aussi
voilà donc là monsieur c'est à mathieu
de sortir au premier tour des autres
jeux très content de vous voir
on a une petite idée de ce que sera
l'émission goûtez ça se dessine tout
doucement à mes amis nos très bons
adversaires
qu'est ce que ça fait de prendre le
salaire des autres listes
merci alors les chéris très vite sur
jambes me tais le sniper cochon de
l'émission et comme les deux sports y
parlera louvre comme on l'appelle le
code dans le cochon tout est bon
alors évidemment chez toi que menton
ouais mais chez toi pas tout est bon
évidemment alors évidemment tu bafouille
et ça ça s'entend ouais tu lustres en
permanence et donc ça brille lui n'a
aucune culture et tu ne regarde jamais
la télé et on va leur dire sa culture
télévisuelle
oui et ça se voit mais malgré ça tu as
un charisme fou tu es un gentleman dans
les loges et habitat le capte
l'angleterre longue ça tombe pile de
l'angleterre londres et mal ça
m'etonnerait fax te vois de france à
coluche le chef sait pas peut sortir
[Applaudissements]
vidéo mettre plus que deux on est très
bien comme ça qui résume pour moi le
mieux nos miss et je ne suis pas
vulgaire je suis grossier merde
bravo voulait que je sorte
et c'est pourquoi pas dans les langes y
avait une super ambiance au sort tout le
monde sait mais je ne reconnais plus
d'émissions qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]